um just talk us through uh firstly i
mean you obviously feel the prime
minister needs to resign at the party
gate but i was quite interested hearing
from some of our viewers who some of
them not all obviously believe that
actually it's time to move on this is a
sideshow there are bigger things to
worry about well i think it is time to
move on it's time to to deal with the
cost of living crisis it's time to deal
with the fact that there are families
and businesses that are struggling to
stay afloat and no help as yet on offer
from government but we can't function as
a country if we have a prime minister
who doesn't tell the truth we can't
function as we saw during covid unless
we're all in it together and that's why
this matters it's not a question of what
happened two years ago in a closed room
in downing street it's a question about
whether the prime minister of this
country who makes the rules feels that
he's above the rules that the rules only
apply to some of us not all of us and
whether in fact we are all in it
together and i think what we've heard
over the last few days suggests very
strongly that this is a prime minister
that has real contempt for those rules
who feels they don't apply to people
like him and that's why you've heard mps
like craig whitaker he and i elected 12
years ago at the same time as new mps
we've been in opposing division lobbies
i think on every issue since but we
speak with one voice on this it's just
simply not good enough and he's got to
go you're going to need more mps like
craig whittaker though aren't you and
more conservative and p's to back this
motion
from labour tomorrow just to explain
what it is you're trying to do
with this motion well we want the
privileges committee to investigate
whether the prime minister misled the
house you'll remember that not very long
ago the prime minister came to
parliament and said there were no
parties it then transpired that there
were parties he then said he wasn't
aware that there had been parties
um and so on and so on he only
apologized in the end when he was caught
he's not sorry that he broke the rules
he's sorry that he was caught i think a
lot of tourists objection isn't it that
is your own subjective analysis of that
boris johnson's uh view is that look he
he in good faith didn't believe rules
were broken boris johnson said no rules
were broken now he says that he didn't
believe rules were broken but i think
you've got to listen to people like
craig whitaker because he speaks for a
lot more tory mps than you're hearing
from on shows like yours i was in the
house of commons today going through the
division lobbies there is a lot of
disquiet it depends how many tory mps
can find the same level of backbone that
craig and a handful of others have done
but i think the fact that the government
is now conceding that they're probably
not going to win this vote without
concessions tomorrow
shows that this is a prime minister in
deep deep trouble every tory mp will be
looking at their inboxes tonight reading
the same stories that i am of people who
lost loved ones who didn't say goodbye
and when the prime minister and his
allies say look this was only a few
minutes a few years ago people would
have given anything to have a few
minutes with people to say goodbye when
they lost loved ones a few years ago it
really matters and it matters that we
uphold decency and integrity in this
country
we on the program been talking quite
about promises questions we heard some
of the exchanges from earlier they're
kind of very angry at you know exchanges
between customer and boris johnson
i guess my question is is there an issue
for labour that it feels
like much of what we're hearing from the
opposition at the minute is anger
towards the government criticism of the
government and not that much about a
positive vision for the country i mean
kirsten is two years into the leadership
now does he not need to start spelling
out a little bit more about an
alternative vision if you guys are
serious about taking over yeah i mean
what's the biggest crisis facing people
in this country right now it's the fact
that inflation is at a 30-year high and
most people watching your show will be
struggling with energy bills here any of
those questions that promises but you
know we've put forward a proposal to the
government which most people back you
had the big bosses of the big energy
companies in parliament this week saying
look we can't deal with this alone one
company one sector can't deal with it we
need government intervention
we've said that we could have a winful
tax on the profits of big energy
companies we could knock hundreds of
pounds of people's energy bills by doing
it and put money back in people's
pockets but if you're talking about
there isn't a security this is thinking
about the the monumental uh crisis that
we face in terms of the cost of living
in terms of energy windfall tax on all
companies we don't need to be a bit more
ambitious than that don't you think need
to talk about some really difficult
decisions uh on energy security yeah
look we're far more ambitious than that
i mean i was the shadow foreign
secretary who came on your show and said
labour got it wrong on russia
not least because we had to get very
tough not just about the interference of
russian money and politics in british
politics but also about our own energy
security we shouldn't be reliant on
countries like russia for energy because
it means bigger bills for people in the
uk but that's precisely the point the
reason that we've got sky-high bills for
people here in the uk is because we're
taking these knee-jerk reactions in
response to major events rather than
foreseeing those events we've degraded
our gas storage capability over the last
decade i was the shadow energy secretary
is warning not to do that we slashed
solar tariffs that supported the growing
solar industry we took the axe to
onshore wind a few years ago under a
tory leadership this has gone on for a
very long time and we've been pushing
the government over the last couple of
years to take seriously the fact that if
you want to cut people's energy bills
you've actually got to invest in home
insulation which the government is
currently cutting of course you've got
to take action in the long term but this
is a crisis right now and the government
should also be taking action in the
short term just finally there's a
critical by-election coming up in
wakefield big test for labour for the
government as well
there's a lot of rumors about ed balls
coming back and standing as a labor
candidate in wakefield
any truth in it well look i don't know i
mean i don't get involved in candidate
selection that's a matter for the
members of wakefield clp i mean i've
watched ed ball's
growing infamy and career with huge
interest as many people have over the
last few years whether he wants to give
up his dancing shoes and return to
politics you know that's a question for
the members of wakefield would you like
to see him return to frontline politics
i've got huge respect for him you know i
worked with him when i was working with
child refugees and he was one of the
people in government who was very
instrumental in making sure that we got
decent treatment for those kids so i've
got a lot of time for ed balls but it's
up to the members in wakefield the point
is surely that we've just had this
appalling incident with the existing
tory mp who's now done the right thing
and stood down we've now got to get a
labour mp re-elected so that those
people in wakefield finally have an mp
that they can be proud of